[Musique]
les l'art du prêcheur pour une autre
culture du risque en martinique c'est
sur ce thème que le mouvement politique
nous plaît tu la veux travailler deux
mains depuis cette commune du prêcheur
bonjour jérémy ferdinand
bonjour maurice violland et bonjour à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui nous
écoutent une martinique 1ère vous êtes
membre du bureau de nos peuples à merci
d'être avec nous aussi con en ce qui
concerne ce phénomène très curieux de
l'art en croit ce phénomène on va les
directio gêne pour les populations
concernées du prêcheur en quoi ce
phénomène pourrait être fédérateur pour
l'ensemble du peuple martiniquais
nous savons tous que la martinique est
un pays qui subit énormément les aléas
climatiques
on parle de cyclones de tremblement
terre de séismes m et aujourd'hui
l'aspect quotidien de l' oppression nous
pousse à avoir une autre gestion des
risques une autre culture du risque et
aujourd'hui les prix chutent à une
expertise qui je pense peut être que tu
es là tous les martiniquais qu'ils ont
des jeunes expertise au bout de deux
trois mois de non c'est pour au bout de
trois mois
l'aude du duo m 3di de demain nous
allons recevoir des historiens qui
parleront notamment de l'histoire de
l'art au prêcheur et on verra que les la
ca diop a duré trois jours mais
culturellement riche de la même
génétiquement s'est inscrit dans le
patrimoine des prix chuter on va le
préciser tout de suite le m3 de celle
midi-minuit monjack organisé par votre
plat régulièrement sur des thèmes bien
précis
nous ne sommes pas prêts face à toutes
les catastrophes qui peuvent survenir
vous les avez vous l'avez les avez cités
mais cette réunionite de l'urgence une
fois que le phénomène est là c'est pas
bon ça tout à fait il s'agit aussi de
contrer toute cette chose effectivement
face à un cyclone nous abordons la chose
à l'instant t mais pour la gestion des
risques et surtout la gestion des crises
il y a une façon d'aborder les choses ya
avant pendant et après et aujourd'hui
les larves du pression ne monte que yani
gestion de crise qui est importante
notamment dans tout ce qui est aléas
climatiques martinique et le m3 d2 de
demain sera essentiellement tourné
autour de ça et pourtant on voit qu'il
ya certaines personnes qui prennent des
initiatives notamment les services de
l'état regardez ce qui s'est passé hier
avec karim wade c'est suffisant pour
vous ce genre d'homme de manifestations
non justement
il faut répéter ces manifestations il
faut avoir une véritable culture du
risque et c'est justement ça que nous
allons d
battre l'après midi au prix cher et il
est important aussi de connaître les
phénomènes
donc on peut aborder la chose de manière
très éloignées c'est vrai péché loin
mais a fait prêchait cdh a fait tout
mâtiné che donc deux mais nous allons
faire une petite randonnée aussi
histoire de bien pâles paix le phénomène
le comprennent avec un géologue qu'on
appelle monsieur mouvoir qui est docteur
à l'université de mexico et à quoi le
saintannais en croit le voc linois en
quoi le point 3 devraient se sentir
concernés
parce qu'avant tout c'est une gestion
des risques c'est une culture est
vraiment s'ils respectent le vous que
vous mettez l'accent exactement c'est
une culture des risques et une culture
aussi des aléas climatiques et
aujourd'hui c'est le prêcheur mais il
faut pas oublier aussi que sous la côte
atlantique ont à la sargasse au site
la saga ce qui représente un certain
danger est aujourd'hui le mode de
gestion de la sargasse et pas forcément
la meilleure des choses
ouais mais on peut prendre exemple sur
ce qui se fait aux pêcheurs qui peut
aussi s'améliorer et qui va certainement
s'améliorer de façon pour que toute la
martinique une gestion une culture du
risque qui est propre
aussi à son histoire et à ses conditions
pédoclimatiques la tribe les antilles
françaises irma sur sa marque on s'en
souvient cour des grandes vacances
dernière c'est un exemple l'actuel
volcan sous marin de grenade le week end
génie en est un autre
à travers tout cela nos plats continue
son message d'une autre approche du
fonctionnement de la société
oui tout à fait en fait c'est un peu nos
let motiv avoir une autre vision de la
société
une autre façon d'impliquer le citoyen
dans la gestion de la société et le m3 d
j'appelle ça personnellement une espace
de souveraineté ou que tout le monde
peut se sentir concerné de ce qui se
passe en martinique et dès le début nous
peuple aa présenté ce mode de
fonctionnement et nièces que ça prend
est ce que ça prend bien soin de vous de
vos simples militants qui sont déjà
acquis à la cause et qui au delà de de
certaines sphères politiques de
certaines sphères intellectuelles est ce
que plus globalement plus généralement
est ce que ça prend la pédagogie c'est
l'art de la répétition et aujourd'hui on
peut se poser la question est ce que ça
a presque s'apprend pas mais la question
véritable il faut se poser c'est est-ce
que ce mode de fonctionnement un
véritable intérêt en martinique et je
réponds que oui
donc ça fonctionne ça fonctionne pas
mais nous nous restons focus sous notre
mode de gestion d'autres modes de
fonctionnement et nous allons répéter
répéter jusqu'à ce que tous les
martiniquais se sentent concernés par la
foule un mode de fonctionnement que l'on
observe dans les plus hautes sphères
étatiques du monde les nations unies
tout à fait tout à fait parce que nous
sommes on n'a rien inventé en réalité
donc on voit que le monde aujourd'hui a
besoin de plus d'explications du citoyen
et dès le début avec notre création 2015
on a dit que avant tout c'est le citoyen
qui décide et le prêcheur pour prenez
qui sont tous les pêcheurs un peu un
exemple en matière de démocratie
participative c'est ce que nous prônons
la responsabilité individuelle de tout
le monde dans l'aspect collectif des
choses près le citoyen qui se sent
délaissé abandonné parce que certains
projets n'aboutissent pas parce que son
pouvoir d'achat est démuni citoyens qui
devient de plus en plus égoïste ça oui
mais c'est parce que la société nous
pousse à devenir et nous disons que ce
n'est pas parce qu'il y aura poussé noah
vu ni égoïste faux finis en réalité on
ne peut pas décider on ne peut pas
décider des choses individuellement et à
la nécessité de se monter un collectif
et nous peuple à ce bel exemple
le collectif de martinique et de divers
aux audois et qui pointe la même chose
un idéal sociétale et on a conscience
qu'elle que ce que l'on se trouve dans
le monde que cette idée associés table
doit être défendue mais essentiellement
par les mobilisations et c'est
essentiellement ce qui fait changer les
choses alors jérémy ferdinand même si
ralph montplaisir n'est pas forcément de
la même tendance politique que vous avez
entendu parler du projet nemo les
complètement procès contre ce projet de
plateforme qui feront de dire et de
l'électricité à partir de la différence
de température de l'eau de mer lorsqu'il
cherche à mobiliser il y à peine une
centaine de personnes seulement à
case-pilote la question de savoir si si
tout le monde se sent concerné en
réalité je pense que même s'il est
difficile de mobiliser les gens je le
conçois et je l'admet c'est vrai il est
difficile de mobiliser les gens les gens
se sentent concernés et aujourd'hui il
faut passer à un autre stade se sentir
concerné et se mobiliser et pour venus à
l'e3 dilemme 3d c'est l'occasion aussi
non seulement de se sentir concernés par
la chose mais ne se mobiliser aussi pour
que les choses changent
alors le mouvement m3 dès ce midi
monjack vous le faites interval assez
régulier ce que c'est suffisant il ce
qu'il ne faut pas le multiplier
justement vous parlez de la rigoureuse
tout à l'heure est ce que vous n'habitez
riez pas par un groupe de services de
l'état à en faire davantage d'exercice
de ce type
en fait il n'y a jamais assez on n'est
jamais assez sensibilisés sur la
question des risques naturels
donc effectivement on pourrait le faire
plus souvent on va certainement le faire
plus souvent mais je pense qu'il faut
déjà commencer par quelque chose et au
début de cette année 2018 c'est un poids
des bienvenues veut pas nous peuple a
crié en décembre 2015 vous l'avez dit
2020 va arriver très vite il y aurait
des municipales il y aura les élections
pour la collectivité territoriale de
martinique nou pep lagarde ce cap
toujours oui nous changeons pas
l'idéologie de nos peuples à ne
changeant pas l'idéal sociétale de nou
pé plat et on sera certainement présent
aux diverses élections ce n'est pas un
mouvement qui va s'essouffler non mais
la preuve lors des élections pour la ctm
il ya eu peu de mouvements qui se sont
plus ou moins que ye nous peuple est
peut-être le seul qui existe aujourd'hui
mais c'est parce qu'on n'est pas motivée
par la question électorale avant tout
nous sommes motivés par cet idéal
sociétal que nous avons cet idéal social
que nous avons et nous travaillons peau
qu'est-ce que vous grossissez est ce que
vous avez de plus en plus de personnes
qui viennent vers vous avec l'intention
d'arborer fièrement vos couleurs
oui nous avons de plus en plus de
personnes qui se sentent sensibilisés
par la cause et on le dit souvent nous
peuple a répond à un besoin un besoin de
faire de la politique autrement
et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que même s'il
est difficile de mobiliser les gens il
est peut-être difficile aussi de que les
gens se déplacent aussi bien puisqu'on
faut pas négliger les conditions
économiques et les conditions sociales
de la martinique
mais les gens sont de plus en plus
propice à venir avec nous à nous paie
plein une l'objectif une antenne de nos
peuples a dans toutes les communes à ce
serait l'idéal
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin on
rappelle jérémy ferdinand que nous
peuple organisera son midi-minuit
monjack autour du thème des l'art les
l'art du prêcheur pour une autre culture
du risque en martinique
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce sera
demain au prêcheur merci merci à vous et
nous avons attendu aux pêcheurs mais
aussi
[Musique]